A former Twitter employee
who gave evidence to the January
six select
committee is speaking out publicly.
The whistleblower says
the committee missed an opportunity
to hold social media
companies accountable
for their roles
in the Capitol insurrection.
CNN's Donie
O'Sullivan has this exclusive report.
I do fear for the future
and what it may hold.
You think there could be
another January six in this country?
Yes.
Anika Collier Navaroli,
is a former Twitter
employee, turned whistleblower
who testified
before the January six committee
initially anonymously.
A lot of the locks and motives
boxed in by
those tweets
were in response to Donald Trump
Now she is speaking exclusively
to CNN in her first television interview.
And I think it's really important
for these findings
from the committee about the roles
that social media played
with in January six come to light.
Navaroli says she can't talk specifics
about her time at Twitter publicly,
but she shared
Eye-opening details
in depositions
with the January six committee.
One example,
as Trump
supporters gathered in Washington, D.C.,
on the eve of the Capitol attack
Navaroli and her colleagues
warned management at Twitter
there might be
someone getting shot tomorrow.
According to transcripts
of her deposition.
But Twitter leadership
refused to take action.
Attorney Alexis Ronickher
spoke to CNN on behalf
of a second Twitter whistleblower
who is remaining anonymous.
Wasn't actually
until the doors of the Capitol
were being breached
that Twitter leadership
started taking action.
At that point,
it was too little, too late.
The real harm and violence had happened
How did you
feel as an American
just seeing this happen? Terrified.
It was horrifying.
To experience
political violence
happen within our country
at such a grand scale.
Jacob Glick was a lawyer
for the January six committee
who deposed narrowly.
She described
employees, including herself,
coming forward to warn
their supervisors in Amicus telling.
They were denied over
and over and over and over and who knows
what could have been avoided.
If they had listened to her
and her colleagues sooner.
But Navaroli is not happy
with the January six
committee's final report.
Social media
companies are mentioned
hundreds of times
within the final report.
However, their role
or their responsibility within that day
and the events of that day
and the violence that occurred
has not been fully laid out.
The committee had a so-called purple team
dedicated to looking into social media
and extremism.
CNN obtained
a copy of an unpublished draft document
the team prepared.
Much of it,
which focused on social media's
role in the run up to January six,
did not make it into the final report.
This is what did not make us into
the final costs.
Social media
companies failed to anticipate
post-election violence.
Social media
platforms had a delayed response
that a rise of far-Right extremism.
Twitter was part
fazed by a fear of political reprisals.
Key decisions at Twitter
were bungled by incompetence
and poor judgment.
I risked a lot
to come forward
and to speak to the committee
and to share the truth
about these momentous
occasions in history.
And I think it is really
a missed opportunity
that the committee
did not include the information
for front and center within their report.
Anika and others say the January
six committee
missed a real opportunity here.
You worked on the committee.
Do you agree with that?
The report did its job exceedingly well,
which was to show the American public
the dangers posed by
President Trump's
multilayered attack on our democracy.
As for the draft document,
Jacob Glick says it includes errors
and shouldn't have been released.
Do you think social media companies
fully appreciate
the role that they played in January 6th?
I don't think so.
That lack of
awareness of responsibility is stark.
By seeing this information
we will be able to understand better
what happened on January six
in order to ensure
that it doesn't
continue to repeat itself.
And social media companies like Twitter
have gone
to great lengths
over the years to explain
what they say
are doing to crack down on violent
rhetoric on their platforms,
including, of course, in the run
up to January 6.
Now, in response
to these whistleblower complaint,
some sources told us, look,
not everything the committee learned
could fit into that final report.